nein nein das war es komplett dieses
mädchen hier was jetzt gerade in die
klasse rein kommt habe ich einfach in
köln mal beim feiern kennengelernt
wir haben auch unsere reise des internet
auf diesem kanal schon sehr viele
schlimme dinge gesehen aber es gibt eine
serie die auf youtube sehr beliebt ist
hier noch gar nicht stattgefunden hat
und dass wird sich verändern werde ich
immer zum allerersten mal eine folge von
cras schule die jungen lehrer anschauen
ich habe schon viele kommentare von euch
bekommen wenn ihr euch genau das
gewünscht hat und heute ist es soweit
wir starten mit keinem geringeren folge
als mit der beliebtesten folge auf dem
kreis schule kanal 4,7 millionen aufrufe
der titel ist kein geringerer als zu
sexy für das klassenzimmer
[Musik]
okay das hier scheint eine lehrerin zu
sein
da packt schon mal vorneweg sagen
zumindest kann nicht wahrscheinlich für
die meisten männlichen meiner zuschauer
sprechen
ganz ehrlich so eine lehrerin hätte ich
damals in meiner schule hätte ich
genommen
da hätte ich im unterricht aufgepasst
schauen wir mal was diese bezaubernde
lehrerin so macht in ihrem alltag ein
neues thema thema zion
was die schülerinnen der schule ist
gerade an der lehrerin vorbeigelaufen
ruft ja dazu bilde billige bis zur l
super der ja also ich weiß wie es bei
euch ist aber ich bin in bayern zur
schule gegangen und für so eine aussage
egal ob im wortwörtlichen kopfschuss
gegeben die haben hier schossen ich
gerade richtig gehört kläger kann sein
dass wir wie so sprach viel hat dieses
schülerin
ich glaube die kann einfach nur drei
worte die kein billiger blöde und bis
das ist ja gerade situation wie redest
du hinterher so hab ich das gerade
richtig gehört die aber so wie hast du
dich gerade genannt so geht's noch egal
was sie gerade ein problem ist es mir
auch egal aber so sprichst du nicht mit
mir
wieso ich habe doch rechts gucken sie
sich doch mal an der ja was ist das für
die schule alter
ich habe keinen bock mehr auf den boden
die begründung ist auch gut so
gucken sie sich mal an wenn die lehrerin
jetzt sogar anfang hätte so fragt das
recht ich bin wirklich eine billige
blöde bild wieso ich habe doch recht
gucken sie sich doch mal an was ist das
für eine kleider länge sie können ja
gleich nach der schule kommen also ich
finde die kleider länger dies vollkommen
ok regal schicksal alter oder witzig
wirklich so ein lehrern hätte ich
genommen also die hätte ich der ich von
akzeptiert wenn ich die so ein biograf
net oder so ist das halt ich in mathe
lehrerin die 65 und leicht übergewichtig
war und gesäubert hat geil starb also
seht ja irgendwo auch rechner das kannst
du vielleicht privat anziehen spitze vor
bei denen will ich doch lieber lassen
sorry aber ist das ne doku über
irgendwas was in der schule passiert und
das ist ein faktum rap battle alter
diebels kostet vor allem sie scheint es
auch mittlerweile so zu akzeptieren
also am anfang war sie so es geht gar
nicht klar was machst du da was soll das
mittlerweile ist sie so okay wir können
auf jeden fall darüber reden warum ich
bin also ich weiß nicht wie realistisch
diese serie sein soll aber ich will es
mal ganz ehrlich mit euch ich glaube
wenn ihr eine schule geht wo es auch
bisschen strenger zugeht können sie das
nachvollziehen
für so was gibt es in vielen schulen in
deutschland einfachen direkten
kopfschuss wenn man eine lehrerin [ __ ]
nennt mehrmals dinger leben vorbei
machst du noch mitbekommen dass die
schülerin ich gerne bis genannt hat das
findet also ordnung
bisher ist sie auch eine lehrerin die
dinge als mary todd schüler und lehrer
sehen an dieser schule einfach exakt
gleich aus wahrscheinlich sind sie auch
gleich alt was was genau geht in dieser
schule habt ist vielleicht nicht das
schönste wort trifft es in jedem fall
aber recht gut als lehrerin ist eine
respektsperson und das funktioniert
einfach nicht wenn irgendwie der helme
hintern raushängt der gala okay weil sie
zu egal normal also dieses kleid ist
wirklich das ist schon heftig ist schon
sehr sehr eindeutig gerade auch sowie
zum ausschnitt wie gesagt also ich als
junge gerade als pubertäre junge damals
hätte man jetzt nicht daran gestört aber
ist wahrscheinlich nicht die beste wahl
wenn man irgendwie als respektsperson
auftreten will
[Musik]
also diese schule ist komplett
geisteskrank die lehrerin hat einfach
ein outfit an was die meisten mädels
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr im club
anziehen würden und sie konnten die
klasse rein und trucking teenager sie
sehen aus als wenn die 17 18 spielen
schubkarre durchs klassenzimmer
wer der 17 18 oder auch überhaupt älter
als zehn ist spielt in seinem leben
ernsthaft schubkarre
naja in jobs gar nicht er hier am
lehrerpult jo macht einlegen so ja blöde
billige [ __ ] mach dein ding ich muss
kurz auch manager
nein nein das war es komplett
das war's aber jetzt mal absolut
komplett am ende komplett aber leute
wartet ich muss so erklären fragt ich
wahrscheinlich warum rastete er zu aus
was war jetzt sie sollen besonders
nichts
doch dieses mädchen hier was jetzt
gerade in die klasse rein kommt habe ich
einfach in köln mal beim feiern
kennengelernt
also ich war mit dem freund zusammen im
klub und hab da die mit ihren
freundinnen klub getroffen haben wir uns
unterhalten und sind danach noch so
weiter einen trinken kann so bis keine
ahnung so ab 7 uhr morgens
und sie hat mir gesagt dass sie bei rtl2
serie mitspielt aber jetzt ist sie
einfach mal drin
ich bin ein bisschen schockiert
ca eigentlich wohnt er in berlin aber
ihre mama ist krank also ist jetzt eine
woche bei mir und das ist okay ganz kurz
also solche leute ihr müsst mich
entschuldigen ich bin wirklich
schockiert zudem fand dazu dass ich
einfach mit hier auf der linken seite
schon feiern war in köln kommt jetzt
fakt dass die auf der rechten einfach
älter aussieht als die lehrerin und die
schülerin an dieser schule geht wirklich
nichts mit rechten dingen zu 90 prozent
aller schüler sehen genau so alt aus wie
die lehrer und sie als schülerin sieht
es einfach älter aus als die lehrer ich
meine hier also das ist wirklich
komplett mein tag für mich heute
versuchen mich zu verstehen okay also er
lernt irgendwo irgendwie personen kennen
beim feiern und unterhalt euch mit der
wada und dann seht ihr diese person
monate später in einem rtl 2
youtube-video mit fünf millionen
aufrufen
da darf man durchaus mal verwirrt sein
na ja geht so das ist ganz wörtlich der
bessere gewinnt da zeigt sich wieder die
sehr hohe produktionsqualität dieser
serie wie er in dem moment sagt möge der
bessere gewinnen sagt das so als wäre
eine frage möge der bessere gewinnen
würde der bessere gewinnt man kann also
gut shoppen gehen ich habe auch gehört
in berlin gibt zwei die coolen clubs
oder ok also sie die jetzt schon der
klasse ist sagt ich habe gehört es gibt
in berlin coole klubs also ist die
schule nicht in berlin sondern die neue
jetzt hier in der runde
die kommt aus berlin nicht aus köln also
zumindest im echten leben also wenn ihr
mich besuchen kommt in den nächsten
ferien womit ihr hier alle eingeladen
seien
unbedingt
nur weil du hast berlin das noch lange
nicht das ist okay berlin
ich bin aus berlin nicht alle besuchen
ich bin die über geister kam am campus
rechtzeitig es anders heute die twister
und es liegt also ich habe glaube ich
herausfinden das liegt natürlich so dass
ist die mit der dieser marvin der
sitzung die neue verliebt hat in joe's
cafe die tat vorher was hatte und sie
ist dementsprechend jetzt ein bisschen
sorge darüber dass jetzt neue da ist die
die aufmerksamkeit von machen hat aber
so ihre begründung dafür dass sie diese
jessica jetzt hast ist so ein bisschen
bisschen weg sagt einfach nur gesagt
dass sie aus berlin kommt und dass sie
sie einlädt auch nach berlin zu kommen
was für eine pid sag mal kamen kann es
sein dass du einfach süchtig bist weil
dein mal wenn er auf jessica steht ja
kleine rote wisst ihr was leute jetzt
jetzt werde ich als wichtig weil jessica
die in echt übrigens heißt jetzt steht
das was mit uns ist das gar nichts mehr
ja heute ich würde sagen eine sehr
saftige folge krass schule gespickt mit
sehr privaten details aus meinem
persönlichen leben übrigens alles was
ihr täter das ist the talk ist wirklich
so passiert es keinen scheiß ich will an
der stelle sagen jessica oder mailin
falls es mit larven nichts wird es laut
einfach in meine wm seien perfekt das
haben wir hier für euch noch einen
persönlich vorgeschlagen das video das
war es so weit von mir leute ich wünsche
euch einen geilen tag und ich küsse
augen macht's gut